Choice Hotels get you more of what you value. Here's a little tune to help you remember. Same drive, different day. Don't you wish you were getting away? Pack your beds and come on through. Texas, Ohio, Alaska, we're up there too. Comfort in. It's calling your name.
Choice Hotels 能让你物超所值。这里有一首小曲子能帮你记住。同样的车程，不同的一天。你难道不希望出去度假吗？收拾好你的床铺，赶快过来吧。德克萨斯州、俄亥俄州、阿拉斯加，我们那里也有。入住舒适酒店。它在呼唤你的名字。
Save on the stay. Oh. And free waffles are yours to claim. Well, I hope you like my little song. Book direct at choiceotails.com. Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. We're in the thick of winter here in the Northern Hemisphere.
节省住宿费用。哦。免费华夫饼等你来拿。好吧，希望你喜欢我的小歌。直接在 choiceotails.com 预订。你好，欢迎收听《心理学话你知》（Speaking of Psychology），这是一档由美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）制作的双周播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。在北半球，我们正处于严冬之中。
By now, many of you are probably tired of the short, cold days and are longing for spring and some sustained sunshine. Even though winter can be a bear, most of us just bundle up, get through it, or embrace it and find ways to get outside and stay active. But as many as six out of every 100 people in the U.S. experience seasonal effective disorder known as sad. It's more than just the winter blues. It can be very difficult for people who suffer from it. And this stretch of winter we're in right now tends to be the most brutal. Our guest on the show today is Dr. Kelly Rowan, a seasonal effective disorder expert who's leading a five-year study on people who suffer from sad at the University of Vermont. Welcome, Dr. Rowan.
到现在为止，你们中的许多人可能已经厌倦了又短又冷的白天，渴望着春天和持久的阳光。尽管冬天的日子可能很难熬，但我们大多数人只是裹紧衣服，熬过去，或者接受它，想方设法走到户外保持活跃。然而，美国有多达千分之六十的人经历着被称为 SAD 的季节性情感障碍。这不仅仅是冬天的忧郁。对于患有这种疾病的人来说，这可能非常困难。而我们现在所处的这段冬天往往是最残酷的。我们今天节目的嘉宾是凯利·罗恩（Kelly Rowan）博士，她是一位季节性情感障碍专家，目前正在佛蒙特大学（University of Vermont）领导一项针对患有 SAD 人群的五年期研究。欢迎你，罗恩博士。
Thank you. My pleasure to be here. I first want to start off with defining what seasonal affect. Disorder. What is the definition? Seasonal effective disorder or sad, I think I'll just call it sad moving forward, is a form of clinical depression that's recurrent. It's major depressive disorder that happens during certain months of the year and is offset or changes to mania or hypomania during the alternative seasons of the year. So I think it surprises a lot of people to hear that seasonal effective disorder sad is actually a subtype of clinical depression.
谢谢。很高兴来到这里。我首先想从定义季节性情感障碍（Seasonal Affective Disorder）开始。什么是定义？季节性情感障碍或 SAD，我想以后我就叫它 SAD，是一种复发性的临床抑郁症。它是发生在一年中特定月份的主要抑郁症，并在一年中的其他季节抵消或转变为躁狂或轻躁狂。所以我想很多人听到季节性情感障碍 SAD 实际上是临床抑郁症的一个亚型时，都会感到惊讶。
Can you explain the difference between sad and depression in general? Really the only thing that makes sad different from garden variety depression that's not seasonal is the seasonal pattern that seasonal affector disorder follows, where we have major depressive episodes recurring predictably in certain seasons of the year. So what are some of the symptoms people experience? So we're diagnosing major depression. The criteria are pretty much the same. We're just looking for the seasonal pattern.
你能解释一下 SAD 和普通抑郁症的区别吗？实际上，使 SAD 与不具有季节性的普通抑郁症有所不同的唯一因素，就是季节性情感障碍所遵循的季节性模式，即重度抑郁发作在一年中的某些季节可预测地复发。那么人们会经历哪些症状呢？所以我们在诊断重度抑郁症时。标准几乎是一样的。我们只是在寻找季节性模式。
and the symptoms include things like feeling pretty persistently down or sad, losing interest or pleasure in things that a person would normally enjoy like their hobbies, interests, social activities, a significant change in weight, which could be a weight gain or a weight loss, or a significant change in appetite, either up or down, sleep disturbances, which could take the form of insomnia, difficulty falling or staying, sleep, or the opposite, what we call hypersomnia, sleeping too much, which could be at night and or in the form of naps that occur during the day. Feeling pretty persistently tired and fatigued, that seems to be the universal symptom of winter
这些症状包括：持续感到情绪低落或悲伤；失去对一个人平时会喜欢的事物的兴趣或乐趣，如爱好、兴趣、社交活动；体重发生显著变化，可能是体重增加或体重减轻；或者食欲发生显著变化，无论增加还是减少；睡眠障碍，可能表现为失眠、难以入睡或保持睡眠，或者相反，也就是我们所说的睡眠过多（hypersomnia），睡得太多，可能发生在夜间和/或白天打盹的形式。持续感到疲倦和疲惫，这似乎是冬季的普遍症状
seasonal effective disorder. I personally never met somebody with sad who doesn't endorse that symptom of feeling this loss of energy nearly every day of the affected months. feeling worthless about oneself or guilty over things that have been done or not done in the past, difficulty concentrating, clarity of mental focus, holding attention, those kinds of things being off. And then recurrent thoughts of death or suicide. We see not only in non-seasonal depression, but about 30% of people who have sad endorse some thoughts of death or suicide. So those are the symptoms of major depressive disorder.
季节性情感障碍。我个人从未遇到过一个患有 SAD 的人，却没有表现出在受影响的几个月里几乎每天都感到精力丧失的症状。对自己感到毫无价值，或者对过去已经做过或未做过的事情感到内疚；注意力不集中，思维清晰度下降，无法保持注意力，这些方面出现异常。然后是反复出现死亡或自杀的想法。我们不仅在非季节性抑郁症中看到这一点，而且大约 30% 患有 SAD 的人也会表现出一些死亡或自杀的想法。这些就是重度抑郁障碍的症状。
and we're looking for at least five of those that are throughout the day, nearly every day, at least two weeks without relenting. And the average sad episode lasts for five months. So we're talking about five months of the year, every year, recurrently suffering from these pretty intense debilitating symptoms. Do those symptoms tend to start, say, as soon as the days get shorter, you know, at the time of year where we fall back, usually in early November? and the days become shorter, it gets colder. Is that when you tend to see this begin? Certainly here in Vermont, where I'm located, the time change, the end of daylight savings, which takes place in early November, is a pretty big queue that seems to set off the cascade of
我们寻找的是其中至少有五种症状，它们是一整天都存在，几乎每天都有，持续至少两周而没有缓解。而平均一次 SAD 发作持续五个月。所以我们谈论的是一年中有五个月，每年如此，反复遭受这些相当强烈、使人衰弱的症状的折磨。这些症状通常会开始，比方说，一旦白天变短，你知道的，在我们把时钟拨慢的那一年中的这个时候，通常在 11 月初？白天变短了，天气变冷了。这就是你通常看到这种状况开始的时候吗？当然，在我所在的佛蒙特州，时间的改变，夏令时的结束（发生在 11 月初），是一个相当大的信号，似乎会引发一系列
symptoms. No two people with that are exactly the same in terms of the timing of the symptoms. But I would say October tends to be a window where the first early onset symptoms, start occurring, and then they pick up momentum in November with a lot more symptoms in December. And January and February tend to be the worst months. Those are the months where the largest proportion of people are going to be in a full-blown major repressive episode among those who have the seasonal pattern to their depression. Do you think that's tied into just the end of the year, all the things going on that might
症状。没有两个患有 SAD 的人在症状出现的时间上是完全一样的。但我会说，10 月份往往是一个窗口期，最早的发作初期症状开始出现，然后在 11 月积聚势头，12 月会出现更多的症状。1 月和 2 月往往是最糟糕的月份。在那些抑郁症具有季节性模式的人群中，这些月份里最大比例的人将处于全面的重度抑郁发作期。你认为这是否与年底有关，所有那些可能会发生的事情有关
keep someone busy, maybe distracted the holidays, that sort of thing? Does that have anything to do with why it might be worse? now it's January and February? I think that it does. There's not a lot of research on this, but I do find that a lot of people kind of make it through the holidays with a lot of effort because they're typically dealing with a lot of fatigue at that time. But there's so many activities that we have to be present for during the holidays, pressure to be at social activities, work holiday parties, those kinds of things. So from a behavioral perspective, those help to keep us a bit more engaged during
让人忙碌，也许节日会让人分心，诸如此类的事情？这是否与它可能变得更糟的原因有关？现在是 1 月和 2 月？我认为确实有关系。这方面的研究不多，但我确实发现，很多人付出了很多努力才勉强度过节日，因为他们在那个时候通常要应对大量的疲劳。但在节日期间，有太多的活动我们需要出席，有参加社交活动的压力、工作节日派对等等。因此，从行为的角度来看，这些有助于让我们在
December. But then after New Year, from the perspective of somebody with winter seasonal effective disorder, it's like, well, now what? Now I just have, you know, at least three, if not more months of winter weather to look forward to. So that is a pretty common trajectory that we see and the sad patients that we work with here. Do you know what causes sad? Is that related to the study you're working on? Well, we don't know what causes sad. We've only been researching this as a recognized mental health diagnosis since the mid-1980s. So it's not too surprising that we haven't figured out what causes seasonal depression yet because we've been researching depression for a lot longer than that and we still don't know exactly what causes depression. probably the leading theory are best educated guess about what causes seasonal effective disorder
十二月。但接着在新年之后，从一个患有冬季季节性情感障碍的人的角度来看，就会觉得，好吧，现在怎么办？现在我至少还有三个月，甚至更多月份的冬日天气要面对。所以这是我们在我们这里接待的悲郁症（SAD）患者身上看到的一个相当普遍的发展轨迹。你知道是什么导致了悲郁症吗？这和你们正在研究的项目有关吗？嗯，我们不知道是什么导致了悲郁症。我们自20世纪80年代中期以来才开始将其作为一种公认的心理健康诊断进行研究。所以我们还没弄清楚是什么导致了季节性抑郁，这其实并不太令人意外，因为我们研究抑郁症的时间要长得多，而且我们仍然不确切知道是什么导致了抑郁症。这或许是关于导致季节性情感障碍原因的主导理论或我们受过良好教育的猜测
is the hypothesis that it's a slow running biological clock in response to the later dawns that occur specifically during the winter months and I think we should separate cause from trigger we think we know what the environmental trigger is to develop winter depression and that's a short photo period. Photo period is day length, simply the number of hours and minutes between dawn and dus sunrise to sunset. And that's, of course, fixed for any given location by calendar date. So there are some studies that show photo period is the strongest, most robust environmental trigger of when the symptoms start in any given year, as well as the strongest predictor of how depressed somebody with seasonal effective disorder feels on a particular day during the winter months. So we think we know
是一个假设，即一个运行缓慢的生物钟，以应对专门在冬季发生的较晚的日出，我认为我们应该将原因与诱因分开，我们认为我们知道引发冬季抑郁的环境诱因是什么，那就是短光周期。光周期就是白天的长度，也就是黎明和黄昏、日出和日落之间简单的小时数和分钟数。当然，对于任何给定的地点，这是由日历日期固定的。因此，有一些研究表明，光周期是一年中症状开始时最强、最稳健的环境诱因，也是预测患有季节性情感障碍的人在冬季的某一天感觉有多抑郁的最强大预测指标。所以我们认为我们知道
what the environmental trigger is. The question is, what is it about a short photo period that triggers the onset of clinical depression in somebody who has a vulnerability to sad? And again, we don't know, but there's some evidence for circadian rhythms getting kind of out of sync during the dark days of winter, usually in the direction of what we call a circadian phase delay, where circadian rhythms are shifted later than they should be in response to a later dawn in the winter months. But it's only about a third of sad patients if we measure the circadian rhythm and melatonin that are going to show that kind of a reaction in the winter as compared to the summer. So it's not like that explains or is a biomarker of every single case of season. effective disorder that's out there. So there's definitely a lot that is not understood. But I did see on your lab's website that women are more likely to suffer from SAID. Do you know why
环境诱因是什么。问题是，短光周期有什么特点，会触发对 SAD 有易感性的人群发作临床抑郁症？再次强调，我们不知道，但有一些证据表明，在黑暗的冬季，昼夜节律会出现某种不同步，通常朝着我们所说的昼夜节律相位延迟（circadian phase delay）的方向发展，即由于冬季较晚的日出，昼夜节律比应有的时间推迟了。但是，如果我们测量昼夜节律和褪黑素，只有大约三分之一的 SAD 患者会在冬季表现出这种反应，而夏天则没有。所以这并不能解释或成为每一个存在的季节性情感障碍病例的生物标志物。因此，绝对有很多地方是人们不理解的。但我确实在你们实验室的网站上看到，女性更容患上 SAD。你知道为什么
that might be? That's the million dollar question. Pretty much every epidemiological study that's ever been conducted specifically on seasonal effective disorder has found overwhelmingly more cases amongst women than men. We think that the gender difference in SAID is at least a high as the gender difference in non-seasonal depression, which is two to one, two women to every male case of major depression. And this is robust. It's replicated pretty much around the world. In seasonal effective disorder, it's believed to be at least that high, if not higher, perhaps
会这样吗？这就是那个价值百万美元的问题。几乎所有专门针对季节性情感障碍进行的流行病学研究都发现，女性病例压倒性地多于男性。我们认为，SAD 中的性别差异至少与非季节性抑郁症中的性别差异一样大，即二比一，每有一个男性重度抑郁症病例，就有两个女性病例。而且这是强有力的。它几乎在世界各地都被复制了。在季节性情感障碍中，人们认为比例至少有这么高，甚至更高，也许
more like four to one women to men who suffer. So it's widely reported in terms of explaining it. I haven't really seen any research that specifically, tries to address that question of why are women more vulnerable than men to seasonal depression? We know in non-seasonal depression, women tend to have a more ruminative response style, meaning when they feel sad or begin to develop depressive symptoms, they turn inwardly and repetitively think over and over again or ruminate about why do I feel this way, how did I get to feel this way, what are the causes and consequences of my feeling
更接近四比一，即女性患病人数与男性患病人数之比。因此，这得到了广泛的报道。在解释它方面，我真的没有看到任何专门试图解决这个问题的研究，即为什么女性比男性更容易患季节性抑郁症？我们知道在非季节性抑郁症中，女性往往有更多的反刍反应风格，这意味着当她们感到悲伤或开始出现抑郁症状时，她们会转向内心，反复思考为什么我会有这种感觉，我是怎么变成这种感觉的，我这种感觉的原因和后果是什么
this way. And there's some evidence in the field of seasonal depression that the more people ruminate in the fall, the more severe their symptoms are the next winter. So there could be something to rumination contributing to the gender difference in seasonal depressive symptoms in the same way that it seems to contribute to the gender difference in non-seasonal depressive symptoms. And that's just a hypothesis or educated guess on my part. And you do know that in northern areas of the U.S. I'm speaking specifically about the U.S. We do have international listeners. But in the U.S., it's more common in the northern states, you know, for New England, where you are in Vermont.
这种方式。并且在季节性抑郁症领域有一些证据表明，人们在秋天的反刍越多，他们第二年冬天的症状就越严重。因此，反刍可能对季节性抑郁症状中的性别差异有所贡献，就像它似乎对非季节性抑郁症状中的性别差异有所贡献一样。这只是我个人的一个假设或有根据的猜测。你知道在美国北部地区。我专门指美国。我们有国际听众。但在美国，它在北部州更常见，你知道的，比如新英格兰，你在佛蒙特州。
But do you see seasonal affective disorder in places that don't have snow or cold weather, say like Florida or, you know, Southern California? Yeah. It seems to exist at southern latitudes, but not nearly at the frequency that we observe at northern latitudes. Some of the first research on this came out of the National Institute of Health in the mid-1980s. They did a telephone survey of residents ranging from Nashua, New Hampshire, which is probably at a similar latitude that I am at here in Burlington, Vermont, all the way down to Sarasota, Florida. And they found a pretty nice correlation with latitude. The further away from the equator you get in the United States, the more cases of seasonal effective disorder you find. the prevalence of Wintersad in Nashua, New Hampshire residents was about 9.7% close to 10% or 1 in 10 people.
但是你在没有雪或寒冷天气的地方，比如佛罗里达州或南加州，能看到季节性情感障碍吗？是的。它似乎存在于较低的纬度，但频率远不及我们在较高纬度观察到的那样。关于这一点的一些早期研究出现在 20世纪80年代中期的国家卫生研究院（National Institute of Health）。他们对从新罕布什尔州纳舒厄（Nashua, New Hampshire，其纬度可能与我所在的佛蒙特州伯灵顿相似）一直到佛罗里达州萨拉索塔的居民进行了电话调查。他们发现这与纬度有着相当不错的相关性。在美国，你离赤道越远，发现的季节性情感障碍病例就越多。新罕布什尔州纳舒厄居民的冬季抑郁症患病率约为 9.7%，接近 10%，也就是每 10 人中就有 1 人。
And in Florida, they still found a 1% prevalence. So 1 in 100 people in Sarasota, Florida may meet criteria for winter seasonal effective disorder. That's really interesting to think a place like Sarasota where you have probably, you know, definitely more sun than you do in the Northeast, warmer days. It could still affect people. I guess maybe, like you said, it might have to do with just the shorter days this time of year. Yeah, there are still our seasons somewhat, not nearly the kinds of fluctuations in photo period that we see at a northern latitude. But you can find those cases. So to me, it suggests there are some people who just cannot outrun their sad, no matter how far south they go.
而在佛罗里达州，他们仍然发现 1% 的患病率。因此，佛罗里达州萨拉索塔每 100 人中就有 1 人可能符合冬季季节性情感障碍的标准。考虑到像萨拉索塔这样一个地方，你可能肯定有比东北部更多的阳光，更温暖的日子，这真的很让人感兴趣。它仍然会影响人们。我想也许，就像你说的，这可能与一年中这个时候白天较短有关。是的，这里仍然在某种程度上存在季节，远没有我们在高纬度地区看到的那么大的光周期波动。但你可以找到这些病例。所以对我来说，这表明有些人无论跑得多南，都无法摆脱他们的 SAD。
If the vulnerability is there, they may still have the depression in the winter months. So I want to talk about your discovery that a form of cognitive behavioral therapy tailored to people of sad was highly effective. Can you explain how CBT helps people with sad and again how that was treated previously? So previously, the first line treatments for winter seasonal effective disorder included light therapy, which has been around since the early 1980s. It was developed specifically as a treatment for winter oppression to try to simulate an early. dawn, based on the assumption that if we do that, we're getting this assumed to be slow-running circadian clock sort of jump-started and put back into a normal phase, more like it is in the wintertime. And there's lots of research from around the world to show that light therapy is a very effective treatment for winter depression. About 50% of people who participated in a controlled trial of light therapy will be in remission at the conclusion of that clinical
如果易感性存在，他们在冬季可能仍然会有抑郁症。所以我想谈谈你的发现，即一种专门针对 SAD 患者的认知行为疗法（CBT）非常有效。你能解释一下 CBT 如何帮助 SAD 患者，以及之前是如何治疗这种疾病的吗？此前，冬季季节性情感障碍的一线治疗包括光疗（light therapy），这种疗法自 20世纪80年代初就已存在。它是专门作为冬季抑郁症的治疗方法开发的，旨在模拟一个早期的
trial. And the other first line treatment previous to my research is antidepressant medications, which include drugs like the SSRIs, the selective serotonergic re-uptake inhibitors, drugs like fluoxetine, brand name Prozac, there was a large study. In Canada, placebo-controlled study of fluoxetine that found it was superior compared to placebo for treating winter depression. And in the United States, the only, to my knowledge, FDA-approved medication for prevention of winter seasonal effective disorder is buproprion XL. So that's the extended release version of buproprion.
黎明，基于这样的假设：如果我们这样做，我们就能让这个被认为是运行缓慢的生物钟重新启动，并恢复到正常的相位，更像冬季时的样子。来自世界各地的许多研究表明，光疗是治疗冬季抑郁症非常有效的疗法。参加光疗对照试验的人中，大约有 50% 的人在该临床试验结束时处于缓解期。在我进行研究之前，另一种一线治疗是抗抑郁药物，包括 SSRI（选择性 5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）等药物，如氟西汀（fluoxetine，商品名百忧解 Prozac），曾有过一项大型研究。在加拿大进行的一项关于氟西汀的安慰剂对照研究发现，它在治疗冬季抑郁症方面优于安慰剂。在美国，据我所知，唯一获得 FDA 批准用于预防冬季季节性情感障碍的药物是安非他酮 XL（buproprion XL）。这就是安非他酮的缓释版本。
Trade name, people may know this drug by the name Welbutrin XL. There was a multi-site study in the United States that found sad patients who started their treatment in the end of summer and followed into, to the fall in the winter, the ones who were getting the active drug, Buproprone XL, had a reduced likelihood of relapse as compared to those that got the placebo. And this led to the FDA approval of Buproprion for the prevention of seasonal effective disorder specifically. So those were the two kind of first-line treatments before my research came along, bright light therapy and antidepressant
商品名，人们可能知道这个药叫韦布曲林 XL（Welbutrin XL）。美国曾进行过一项多中心研究，结果发现，在夏末开始治疗并持续到秋季和冬季的 SAD 患者中，服用活性药物安非他酮 XL 的患者与服用安慰剂的患者相比，复发可能性降低了。这促使 FDA 专门批准安非他酮用于预防季节性情感障碍。所以在我的研究问世之前，这就是两种主要的一线治疗方法，强光疗法和抗抑郁
medications. Now I think it's out there in the universe, more or less accepted that cognitive behavioral talk therapy is another effective form of treatment for winter seasonal effective disorder. Cognitive behavioral therapy, CBT, is a tried and true psychotherapy treatment for non-seasonal depression. It's been around since the 1960s. There's a lot of clinical trials from around the world to show that it's effective treatment for depression. And it seems to have lasting benefits after treatment ends in terms of keeping people well over time, reducing risk of relapse and recurrence. So when I first had the idea in the mid-1990s about applying cognitive behavioral therapy CBT to SAD, I thought, wouldn't it be nice if we could treat these people once with a psychotherapy like CBT?
药物。现在我认为它已经在世界上广为人知，或多或少被接受，即认知行为谈话疗法是治疗冬季季节性情感障碍的另一种有效疗法。认知行为疗法（CBT）是针对非季节性抑郁症的一种久经考验的心理治疗方法。它自 20世纪60年代就已经存在。来自世界各地的许多临床试验表明，它是治疗抑郁症的有效方法。在治疗结束后，它似乎具有持久的益处，能够在一段时间内保持人们的健康，降低复发和再次发作的风险。因此，当我在 20世纪90年代中期首次萌生将认知行为疗法 CBT 应用于 SAD 的想法时，我想，如果我们能用像 CBT 这样的心理治疗对这些人进行一次治疗，那该有多好。
And they learn something that they can carry forward into future winners to fortify themselves against a relapse. And we know that this is generally true of cognitive behavioral therapy for depression. So why not try it with seasonal effective disorder to have an alternative out there? Again, it's about 50% of people who remit with light therapy. So the other 50% needs something. and not everybody is willing or able to take a medication. Some people can't tolerate side effects.
并且他们学到了一些东西，可以带到未来的冬天，以增强自己抵抗复发的能力。我们知道，这通常适用于治疗抑郁症的认知行为疗法。那么为什么不尝试将其用于季节性情感障碍，以提供另一种选择呢？同样，通过光疗缓解病情的人大约占 50%。所以另外 50% 的人需要一些东西。而且并非每个人都愿意或能够服用药物。有些人无法耐受副作用。
So I was really interested in the idea of a non-pharmacologic alternative to light therapy. And can you explain why light therapy works? So it's based on the dogma that seasonal effective disorder is caused by a slow running biological clock in response to later dawns in the winter. So if we give someone morning light therapy, which is the superior time to administer it in the course of a day relative to in the evening, if we give someone morning light therapy, we're doing it with the goal of simulating an early dawn, a dawn that would be more like it is in the summer, to presumably jumpstart a slow running circadian clock and put those circadian rhythms back into a normal phase, more like they are in the summer, the summertime. So the circadian rhythms we look at most frequently because you can measure it is the circadian rhythm in the hormone of darkness melatonin. Melatonin rises at night to help us feel sleepy and it tapers off in the morning to help us wake up. The assumption is in people with seasonal affective disorder, they're in a sense of biological night much later in the morning than
所以我对光疗的非药物替代方案的想法非常感兴趣。你能解释一下为什么光疗有效吗？所以它是基于这样一个教条，即季节性情感障碍是由冬季较晚的日出引起的运行缓慢的生物钟所致。因此，如果我们给某人进行晨间光疗，这是在一天中相对于晚上更优的施用时间，如果我们给某人进行晨间光疗，我们的目标是模拟一个早期的黎明，一个更像夏天的黎明，据此来重新启动运行缓慢的生物钟，并将这些昼夜节律带回正常相位，更像夏天、夏季时那样。因此，我们最常研究的昼夜节律，因为你可以测量它，就是黑暗荷尔蒙褪黑素的昼夜节律。褪黑素在夜间上升，帮助我们感到困倦，并在早晨逐渐减少，帮助我们醒来。假设在患有季节性情感障碍的人中，他们在早晨很长一段时间内仍然处于生物学上的夜晚，
they should be. Their melatonin is still being released by the pineal gland, even though the alarm clock is going off and, you know, they're getting these external cues. It's time to wake up. Their bodies are telling them, I should still be asleep. It's still internally night because they're still producing melatonin. So the bright light therapy first thing in the morning is designed to suppress that melatonin release and jumpstart that slow running melatonin rhythm back into the normal phase, more like it is in the summer months. And this is all assumed based on theory, not really demonstrated in research, that that's the mechanism through which light therapy works. Yeah, that leads me to my next question about this research you're doing, this five-year clinical
比他们应有的时间要晚。尽管闹钟已经响了，并且，你知道的，他们正在接受这些外部线索，现在是时候醒来了，但他们的身体仍在由松果体释放褪黑素。他们的身体在告诉他们，我应该还在睡觉。在内部它仍然是夜晚，因为他们仍在产生褪黑素。因此，清晨的第一束强光疗法旨在抑制褪黑素的释放，并将运行缓慢的褪黑素节律重新启动回到正常相位，更像是夏天的月份。这一切都是基于理论的假设，并没有真正在研究中得到证实，即这就是光疗起作用的机制。是的，这引出了我的下一个问题，关于你正在做的这项研究，这个为期五年的临床
trial. It's funded by the National Institute of Mental Health. And in it, there's 160 adults with sad, and they'll be either treated with that sad-tailored CBT or light therapy and then followed over two years. Can you talk about where you are with this study now? Are you able to share some initial findings or what you're learning so far? Yeah, well, it's a good thing for me that I have a really high frustration tolerance and I can delay gratification. Because the kind of work that I do is very slow and deliberate and pace. I run randomized clinical trials comparing light therapy and CBT sad. We treat people and then we follow them for the next two winters.
试验。它由美国国家精神健康研究所（National Institute of Mental Health）资助。其中有 160 名患有 SAD 的成年人，他们将接受量身定制的 SAD CBT 治疗或光疗，然后进行为期两年的随访。你能谈谈你目前这项研究进展到什么地步了吗？你能分享一些初步发现或者到目前为止你学到了什么吗？是的，好吧，对我来说幸运的是，我有很高的挫折忍受力，我能够延迟满足。因为我所做的工作是非常缓慢、深思熟虑且有条不紊的。我进行随机临床试验，比较光疗和 SAD CBT。我们治疗人们，然后在接下来的两个冬天对他们进行随访。
So at this stage of the game, we have only treated our very first cohort of participants last winter. They're coming back for follow-up this winner, and we're just now enrolling and beginning to treat our second cohort of participants. So even though we have about 90 people currently active in the study, we're so early in our data collection that we don't really know any findings that I could talk about in a meaningful way. However, the last study that we did, which was very similar to this one, enrolled 177 community adults in the greater Burlington area with Winter Sad. We treated them with flight therapy or CBT SAD, and we followed them for two winters. In that study, we found both flight therapy and CBT SAD were very effective treatments across six weeks in the winter. They could not be split out if it were a horse race. it would be a dead heat.
所以在现阶段，我们在去年冬天只治疗了第一批参与者。他们这个冬天要回来接受随访，我们现在才刚刚招募并开始治疗我们的第二批参与者。因此，尽管我们目前有大约 90 人积极参与这项研究，但我们的数据收集还处于早期阶段，我们其实并不知道任何我可以有意义地谈论的发现。然而，我们进行的上一项研究与这项研究非常相似，在大伯灵顿地区招募了 177 名患有冬季 SAD 的社区成年人。我们用光疗或 SAD CBT 对他们进行了治疗，并对他们进行了两个冬天的随访。在那项研究中，我们发现光疗和 SAD CBT 在冬天的六周内都是非常有效的治疗方法。如果这是一场赛马，它们是无法分出高下的。这将是一场平局。
And we've tried, like, you know, what if we consider certain profiles, better candidates for one versus the other? We cannot seem to split those treatments out across six weeks. But when we followed people for the next two winters, we found apparent two winters later fewer relapses and less severe symptoms in the winter in people who got the CBT intervention relative to those who got the light therapy intervention. Exactly the same pattern that we observe in non-seasonal depression with CBT studies as compared to antidepressant medications. Both treatments work really great in the initial phase,
我们尝试过，比如，如果我们考虑某些特征，哪些人更适合其中一种疗法而不是另一种？在六周的时间里，我们似乎无法区分这些疗法。但是，当我们对人们进行接下来的两个冬天随访时，我们发现在随后的两个冬天里，接受 CBT 干预的人与接受光疗干预的人相比，复发率更低，冬天的症状也更轻微。这与我们在 CBT 研究中观察到的非季节性抑郁症的模式完全相同，与抗抑郁药物相比。这两种疗法在初始阶段都非常有效，
but then a reduced risk of relapse and better outcomes following treatment in CBT. So is your goal with this research to back up more thoroughly that CBT is the best course of action, or the one that will have the most long-lasting benefits? The grant that I got that's funding the current study is called a confirmatory efficacy R-O-1 trial in National Institute of Mental Health Lingo. So what that means is confirmatory efficacy, that you already have quite a bit of data to show that a treatment works, and this is just confirming that, consistent with the doubting nature of science.
但随后在 CBT 中复发风险降低，治疗后的效果更好。那么，你的这项研究的目标是更彻底地证实 CBT 是最佳行动方案，还是会带来最持久益处的方案？我获得的资助当前研究的基金被称为国家精神健康研究所（NIMH）术语中的验证性疗效 R-O-1 试验（confirmatory efficacy R-O-1 trial）。所以这意味着验证性疗效，即你已经有了相当多的数据来证明一种治疗方法有效，这只是在证实这一点，这符合科学持怀疑态度的本质。
When you show a result once, that's great, but we always wonder. Is it legitimate? So we replicate over and over again. So that's the goal of this study. In addition, we're studying some biomarkers that we think will be mechanistic of treatment outcomes in light therapy and cognitive behavioral therapy. We're basically doing a neuroscience clinical trial here. I'm doing things I never dreamed I would be doing.
当你展示一次结果时，这很棒，但我们总是会想。这是合法的吗？所以我们一遍又一遍地复制。这就是本研究的目标。此外，我们正在研究一些生物标志物，我们认为这些生物标志物将是光疗和认知行为疗法治疗结果的机制。我们基本上在这里做一个神经科学临床试验。我正在做我做梦也没想到我会做的事情。
I have a research grade pupilometer and EEG system in the lab. and we're repeatedly measuring things like pupillary responses to light, the circadian rhythm and melatonin, pupillary responses to emotional information, including seasonal or winter-specific stimuli, repeatedly over the course of treatment and in our follow-ups one and two years later. And what we're hoping to learn is some cause and effect relationships, specifically what changes in the body that proceeds and predicts an improvement in depression in the acute phase. And what is responsible for this enduring effect that we see in CBT SAD specifically with regard to fewer relapses and less severe symptoms in future winters. Yeah, that's really fascinating. And so you have one more year of
我的实验室里有一个研究级别的瞳孔计（pupilometer）和脑电图（EEG）系统。我们正在重复测量诸如对光的瞳孔反应、褪黑素的昼夜节律、对情绪信息的瞳孔反应（包括季节性或冬季特定的刺激），在治疗过程中以及一年和两年后的随访中重复进行。我们希望了解的是一些因果关系，具体来说，身体发生了哪些变化，先于并预测了急性期抑郁症的改善。是什么原因导致了我们在 SAD CBT 中看到的这种持久效果，特别是在未来冬天的复发更少、症状更轻微方面？是的，这真的很迷人。所以你还有一年的时间
this research and then you'll be publishing, I'm imagining, right? Actually, we have three more years of this research. It's a five-year grant. And we recruit, a new cohort each year for the first three years, but then because we follow everyone for two years, it takes five years to complete the project. So that's what I meant by. It's a good thing I can delay gratification. Yeah, okay. Yeah, I see what you mean. I think I was a little bit confused. I was saying you follow people for two years. So there's still more time on the study. So they'll be interesting to see what comes to light. And that leads me to my next question about when you and I spoke earlier about this topic, you were explaining how important
这项研究，然后你就会发表，我想象是这样的，对吧？事实上，这项研究我们还有三年时间。这是一项为期五年的资助。在前三年中，我们每年招募一个新的队列，但因为我们对每个人进行两年的随访，所以完成这个项目需要五年时间。这就是我的意思。幸好我能延迟满足。是的，好吧。是的，我明白你的意思。我想我有点糊涂了。我说的是你对人们进行了两年的随访。所以这项研究还有更多的时间。所以看到会有什么结果公布将会很有趣。这让我想到了我的下一个问题，关于你和我早些时候谈论这个话题时，你解释了光疗在监督下进行是多么重要，人们不应该随便跑去买一盏灯。所以你能解释一下为什么像光疗这样治疗需要在监督下进行吗？光疗让我非常感兴趣，因为它不受 FDA 监管。这有点像一个家庭作坊产业。外行很难浏览市场上所有的产品。购买灯箱不需要处方。
it is that light therapy be done under supervision, that people not run out and go by a lamp. So can you explain why it's important for something like light therapy to be done under supervision? Light therapy is very interesting to me, and that it is not FDA regulated. It's a sort of cottage industry. It's really hard for a layperson to navigate all of the products that are on the market. You don't need a prescription to buy a light box. Technically, anybody could go online and acquire a device without any kind of prescription.
从技术上讲，任何人都可以上网购买设备，而不需要任何处方。
But that doesn't mean that you should because, first of all, you want to make sure that you're getting a device that meets the specifications of those that have been tested in the randomized clinical trials. And generally, that means 10,000 lux intensity with a UV filter, so you're not going to burn your skin or your retinas. bigger is better. A lot of these tiny devices that are on the market, those of us in the field, worry, are they really effective? Because it seems like very minor movements of the head may no longer get the 10,000 lux to the retina, whereas the big ones that have been tested in clinical trials, if you're in front of it, facing it, you're probably going to get that full dose of light to the retina. So that's the first thing, navigating the industry, finding a product that could be truly effective.
但这并不意味着你应该这样做，因为首先，你要确保你买到的设备符合在随机临床试验中测试过的产品的规格。一般来说，这意味着 10,000 勒克斯的强度带有紫外线过滤器，这样你就不会灼伤皮肤或视网膜。越大越好。市场上有很多微小的设备，我们这个领域的专家担心，它们真的有效吗？因为头部非常微小的移动似乎可能无法再将 10,000 勒克斯的光照射到视网膜上，而在临床试验中测试过的大型设备，如果你在它前面，面向它，你很可能会接受到全剂量的光照射到视网膜上。所以这是第一件事，浏览这个行业，找到一个真正有效的产品。
And then secondly, is dosing. There is no one-size-fits-all prescription to light therapy, despite what any instructions might say that come with a device. By dosing, I mean how many minutes per day does this individual need to use it? And at what specific time or times of day does this person need to use it? We initiate light therapy at 30 minutes in the morning, first thing upon waking in my clinical trials. But just like dosing a medication, that's a starting dose. We always start at the floor.
然后第二个是剂量。光疗没有一刀切的处方，不管设备附带的任何说明书上怎么说。所谓剂量，是指这个人每天需要使用多少分钟？这个人需要在一天中的什么特定时间或哪些时间使用它？在我的临床试验中，我们在早晨醒来的第一件事就开始进行 30 分钟的光疗。但就像给药物设定剂量一样，这是一个起始剂量。我们总是从最低的开始。
That's the minimal dose that it would take for somebody to benefit. And we work from there. We titrate up. And the third thing is side effects. Light therapy can have side effects. Usually these include things like headaches, eye strain, feeling a little wired up. The more rare but serious side effects, light therapy can contribute to some pretty significant insomnia because it is assumed to shift circadian rhythms around, including the circadian rhythm
那是某人受益所需的最小剂量。我们从那里开始。我们逐渐向上调整。第三个是副作用。光疗可能会产生副作用。通常这些包括头痛、眼疲劳、感觉有点亢奋等。更罕见但严重的副作用是，光疗可能会导致一些相当严重的失眠，因为人们假设它会改变昼夜节律，包括昼夜节律
and melatonin, but there's also a circadian rhythm in sleep. In addition, the rare but serious side effect that I think it would be very dangerous for a layperson to encounter without anyone monitoring them is the possibility of mania or hypomania, the elevated mood states, usually associated with bipolar disorder, what we used to call manic depression. We see it sometimes in light therapy. It's rare but certainly serious. Yes, and you told me earlier as well that one third of people with SAID may have bipolar presentation. That means they go to the opposite under the spectrum during warmer months where they have active thoughts, high energy, fast thoughts, talking fast, very little need for sleep. Why do you think that is? So the National Institute of
和褪黑素，但睡眠也有昼夜节律。此外，我认为对于外行来说，在没有人监督的情况下遇到这种罕见但严重的副作用是非常危险的，那就是躁狂或轻躁狂的可能性，即通常与双相情感障碍（我们过去称之为躁狂抑郁症）相关的情绪高涨状态。我们在光疗中有时会看到这种情况。这很罕见，但当然很严重。是的，你之前也告诉我，三分之一的 SAD 患者可能会出现双向情感障碍的表现。这意味着在温暖的月份里，他们会走向光谱的另一端，在那里他们会有活跃的想法、高能量、思维敏捷、语速快、对睡眠的需求极少。你认为这是为什么呢？所以国家精神
Mental Health, which was the pioneering group under Norman Rosenthal, MD, psychiatrist, who coined the term seasonal effective disorder, did the original studies to develop the diagnostic at criteria, surveillance, and so on, found that in over 800 people that came through their seasonal studies program, it was 60% that had a unipolar presentation, meaning it was major depressive disorder in the fall in the winter, and then a full remission or change to normal mood in the spring and the summer. For the remaining 40%, about 35% of those individuals had a bipolar two presentation, which means they were depressed in the fall and the winter, but their mood changed to hypomania, the less severe variant of mania in the spring and the summer. And about 5% had a
健康研究所（National Institute of Mental Health）是诺曼·罗森塔尔（Norman Rosenthal，医学博士、精神病学家）领导下的先驱小组，他创造了“季节性情感障碍”这个词，进行了最初的研究以制定诊断标准、监测等，发现在通过他们的季节性研究项目的 800 多人中，60% 表现为单相情感障碍，这意味着它在秋季和冬季是重度抑郁障碍，然后在春季和夏季完全缓解或转变为正常情绪。对于其余 40% 的人，其中大约 35% 的个体表现为双相二型（bipolar two），这意味着他们在秋季和冬季抑郁，但在春季和夏季情绪变为轻躁狂（躁狂的不太严重的变体）。大约 5% 的人表现为
bipolar 1 presentation, where they had full-blown manic symptoms in the spring and the summer. Seasonality, we tend to associate it with depression predominantly. However, it is kind of a transatlantic diagnostic construct. So there are seasonal cases that have been reported, at least in a form of case studies, for anxiety disorders, panic disorder specifically, eating disorders, particularly bulimia nervosa, but now that binge eating disorder is a recognized category, we're finding that that's a pretty significant comorbidity as well. A lot of our sad patients have that, and people with binge eating disorder can have a seasonal pattern to their binge eating and also substance use disorders. It's been reported that they can have a seasonal component as well. So I think seasonality
双相一型（bipolar 1），他们在春季和夏季有全面的躁狂症状。季节性，我们倾向于主要将它与抑郁症联系起来。然而，它有点像一个跨大西洋的诊断结构。因此，已经报告了季节性病例，至少以个案研究的形式，针对焦虑障碍、特别是惊恐障碍、进食障碍（特别是神经性贪食症），但现在暴食症已被确认为一个公认的类别，我们发现这也是一个相当显著的共病。我们的许多 SAD 患者都有这种情况，患有暴食症的人其暴食也可能具有季节性模式，还有物质使用障碍。据报道，它们也可能具有季节性成分。所以我认为季节性
is really kind of a transdiagnostic construct. We tend to think of it as a course specifier for mood disorders, but other psychopathologies can have a seasonal pattern as well. I've also read that people can get seasonal depression in the summer. Do you know why someone would get seasonal effective disorder in the summer? I mean, the days are longer, the weather's warmer, or the sun's out? Yeah, we've really been focusing our conversation on winter sad, and I've even used the term sad kind of generically to refer to winter sad throughout our conversation today. But it's important to note that the diagnostic criteria are actually silent in terms of what the seasonal pattern needs to look like. As long as we have major depression that recur specifically in certain seasons
真的是一种跨诊断结构。我们倾向于将其视为情绪障碍的病程说明符，但其他精神病理学也可能具有季节性模式。我也读到过人们可以在夏天患上季节性抑郁症。你知道为什么有人会在夏天患上季节性情感障碍吗？我的意思是，白天更长，天气更暖和，或者阳光普照？是的，我们真的把谈话集中在冬季 SAD 上，甚至在今天的谈话中，我也一直笼统地使用 SAD 这个词来指代冬季 SAD。但重要的是要注意，诊断标准实际上并未说明季节性模式应该是什么样子。只要我们在一年中的某些特定季节复发重度抑郁症，
of the year, we can consider it sad. We do see in epidemiological studies or surveillance studies, a minority of sad cases have a summer presentation where they have the major depressive symptoms in the summer months. And these people actually feel their very best in the fall and the winter months at the National Institute of Mental Health, they did a little bit of research, very small studies, very small sample sizes. And predominantly, by the way, with individuals who had bipolar-type seasonal effective disorder. And what those patients reported was they felt that their trigger was more related to heat and humidity, or perhaps too much light in the spring and the summer that would usually trip them in terms of a sudden mood change in the spring or the summer
我们就可以认为它是 SAD。我们在流行病学研究或监测研究中确实看到，少数 SAD 病例表现为夏季发作，他们在夏季表现出重度抑郁症状。这些人实际上在国家精神健康研究所的秋季和冬季感觉最好，他们做了一些研究，样本量非常小，样本量非常小。而且顺便说一句，主要是个体患有双相型季节性情感障碍的人。这些患者报告说，他们觉得他们的诱因更多地与炎热和潮湿有关，或者可能是在春季和夏季有太多的光线，这通常会在春季或夏季导致他们突然的情绪变化
months. So we think the trigger is very different for one thing. Heat and humidity and summer sad and short photo period or light deprivation in winter sad. The treatments that they experimented with at the NIMH were thermoregulatory treatments, having these individuals take cold showers frequently throughout the day. can find themselves to air conditioning. And it seemed to be helpful.
月份。因此，我们认为诱因完全不同。炎热和潮湿以及夏季 SAD，与短光周期或冬季 SAD 中的光线剥夺。他们在 NIMH 试验的疗法是体温调节疗法，让这些个体在一天中频繁洗冷水澡。可以让自己呆在空调里。这似乎很有帮助。
But again, it's at such a small level, this research, small sample sizes. I hesitate to make any definitive conclusions or put any treatment recommendations out there. So if someone does experience this, what's the best course of action? If somebody experiences Somersad, probably find a provider who's experienced in dealing with sad in general because they could help make sure once and for all. that this is really a definitive diagnosis, try to rule out any psychosocial stressors that could be responsible that are not related to an environmental trigger. Clinically, I think people are likely to use antidepressant medications, potentially CBT, with some of the same focus that we do
但话又说回来，这项研究的样本量很小，水平还很初级。我不敢轻易下任何绝对的结论，也不敢提出什么治疗建议。那么如果有人经历了这种情况，最好的应对措施是什么呢？如果有人患有夏季情感障碍，最好找一位擅长处理一般抑郁症的医疗人员，因为他们可以最终帮助确诊这确实是一个明确的诊断，并尽量排除任何与环境诱因无关的社会心理应激源。在临床上，我认为人们可能会使用抗抑郁药物，或者认知行为疗法（CBT），其关注点可能与我们平时做的类似
with the winter seasonal effective disorder, behavioral activation, identifying challenging and changing negative thoughts. In this case, I guess it would be negative thoughts about the summer. I'm so used to dealing with the negative thoughts about the winter. I don't think there's a case for light therapy because we have plenty of light. There's more light in the summer. So I can't imagine a scenario for light therapy being effective for summer sad. But antidepressants, psychotherapy, perhaps CBT specifically, and potentially some of these thermoregulatory treatments that were experimented with by Norman Rosenthal. Thomas Weir and colleagues at the National Institute of Mental Health.
针对冬季季节性情感障碍的方法一样，比如行为激活、识别挑战和改变消极思维。在这种情况下，我想这应该是关于夏天的消极思维。我太习惯于处理关于冬天的消极思维了。我认为光疗在这里行不通，因为我们有充足的光线，夏天的光线更多。所以我无法想象光疗对夏季情感障碍有效的场景。不过，抗抑郁药、心理治疗（也许尤其是认知行为疗法），以及诺曼·罗森塔尔（Norman Rosenthal）、托马斯·威尔（Thomas Weir）及其在国家心理健康研究所的同事们曾尝试过的一些体温调节治疗，可能会起作用。
So a great deal of your professional life, as we've been talking about, is studying sad. And, you know, yet there are some people out there, including mental health professionals who don't believe there's a variation in depressive symptoms based on the seasons. So what do you say to that? I wonder if they've ever lived in Vermont. Come to Vermont, where on the winter solstice, our photo period, from sunrise to sunset, is about eight hours. I think anybody with a clinical practice that services a lot of mood disorders, patients at a more northern location would probably appreciate the seasonality that they see
正如我们一直在讨论的，你的大半职业生涯都在研究季节性情感障碍。然而，有些人（包括心理健康专家）并不认为抑郁症状会随季节而变化。对此，你想说些什么？我怀疑他们是否在佛蒙特州生活过。来佛蒙特州看看吧，在这里的冬至时节，从日出到日落的白昼时间大约只有八个小时。我认为任何临床诊疗服务过大量北方地区情绪障碍患者的医生，大概都会对他们在患者身上看到的这种季节性深有体会。
in their patients. There's a large research base here. I don't quite understand that way of thinking, of doubting the validity of seasonal depression. Certainly the construct of depression, it seems quite global and robust over time. It's widely recognized that that's a legitimate mental health problem. We think that about 10 to 20 percent of recurrent mood disorders have at least some kind of seasonal component. And we have theories that are kind of unique to explaining at least potentially some of the mechanisms linking low light availability to depression. We have a treatment light therapy that was designed specifically for this population with good efficacy. So I think we need to let the data speak that it looks like there is a subset of individuals out there that have a seasonal pattern to their depression.
这里有着庞大的研究基础。我不太理解那种怀疑季节性抑郁真实性的思维方式。当然，抑郁症这一概念随着时间的推移，在全世界范围内都显得相当普遍且坚实。人们普遍承认这是一种合法的心理健康问题。我们认为，大约百分之十到二十的复发性情绪障碍至少带有某种季节性成分。我们有一些独特的理论，至少有可能解释将低光照水平与抑郁联系起来的部分机制。我们有一种专门为这一群体设计的、疗效很好的治疗方法——光疗。因此，我认为我们应该让数据说话，表明确实有一部分人的抑郁症呈现出季节性模式。
And if you take a look at the literature, there's quite a body of work that's been done to support that. So in addition to my hosting duties here on speaking of psychology, I also work in APA's public affairs office where I field media inquiries. And this time of year, we get a lot of media inquiries about seasonal affective disorder for obvious reasons. So do you think seasonal effective disorder is well understood by the general public? And what are some misconceptions you think there are about it out there? I think that the general public is aware of it and fascinated by it. It's certainly a topic that lay people can relate to. It's a disorder that, in my opinion, happens on a continuum where seasonal effective disorder is the extreme variant, clinical depression that's fully impairing.
如果你查阅相关文献，会发现有很多研究成果都支持这一观点。因此，除了担任本期《心理学对话》的主持人外，我还兼职于美国心理学会的公共事务办公室，负责处理媒体问询。每年这个时候，出于显而易见的原因，我们会收到大量关于季节性情感障碍的媒体问询。那么，你认为公众对季节性情感障碍的理解透彻吗？你觉得人们对它有哪些误解？我认为公众对它有所了解并且很感兴趣。这绝对是一个外行人能够产生共鸣的话题。在我看来，这种障碍存在于一个连续体上，其中季节性情感障碍是极端形式，也就是完全影响正常生活的临床抑郁症。
but most people at a high latitude are going to have some symptoms. It's just a question of how many and how bad, how impairing are those symptoms. So there is data to show seasonality is normally distributed at higher latitudes. Most people, and I say this all the time here when I do community talks, most people at a high latitude like we have here at 45 degrees north, Burlington, Vermont, are going to sleep a bit more in the winter. feel a bit more fatigued, have some appetite changes, preferences towards carbohydrate, enriched foods. That's all normal. That's normal seasonality. People with no seasonality are really
但高纬度地区的大多数人都会有一些症状。这只是症状有多少、有多严重、对生活造成多大影响的问题。因此，有数据显示，季节性在较高纬度地区呈正态分布。大多数人——我每次做社区讲座时都这么说——在高纬度地区（比如我们这里北纬45度的伯灵顿，佛蒙特州），冬天都会睡得稍微多一点，感觉更疲劳一些，食欲会有所改变，更偏爱富含碳水化合物的食物。这都是正常的。这就是正常的季节性。完全没有季节性的人才是
the other extreme variant, people that literally feel the same year round. That would be quite rare at a northern latitude like this. So I think the fascination by the public and by the media is that people recognize this and they relate to it. I think light therapy as a treatment that is disseminated, people are widely aware of light therapy as an effective treatment option. Yeah, so there's still a lot out there that we're learning, and I'm really interested to learn the results of your study. One quick question before we wrap up is,
另一种极端情况，即一年到头感觉完全一样的人。在像我们这样的北方高纬度地区，这相当罕见。因此，我认为公众和媒体的着迷之处在于人们能够理解并产生共鸣。我认为作为一种普及的治疗方法，光疗作为一种有效的治疗选择，已经广为人知。是的，所以我们还有很多东西需要去了解，我真的很有兴趣了解你们研究的结果。在结束之前还有一个小问题：
so say you don't have seasonal affectives disorder, but you might get some winter blues. Like you said, most people experience some. symptoms of, you know, not feeling their best during the winter or sleeping more or eating more or whatnot. What are some tips listeners can take away to kind of keep their spirits up until spring? So if it's just mild winter blues, which I think is very relatable at a high latitude and not actually clinical depression in the winter, I think some of the principles from the behavioral side of cognitive behavioral therapy could help people cope what we call behavioral activations.
假设你没有季节性情感障碍，但你可能会患上一些“冬季抑郁”（winter blues）。就像你说的，大多数人都会经历一些症状，你知道的，比如冬天感觉状态不佳、睡得更多或吃得更多等等。听众可以采取哪些小贴士来保持好心情，直到春天到来呢？所以，如果只是轻微的冬季抑郁，我认为在高纬度地区这非常容易引起共鸣，它其实并不是冬天的临床抑郁症，我认为认知行为疗法中行为方面的某些原则可以帮助人们应对，这就是我们所说的行为激活。
which is the idea of staying active and engaged during the winter. If you like winter sports, great. That's a really good way to approach winter, get some physical activity, get a sense of enjoyment. But you can think outside of the box, skiing, snowboarding, ice skating, snow-shoeing. Those aren't the only things that you can do in the winter. There's nothing wrong with indoor activities. Take a class. Stay active in a group.
也就是在冬天保持活跃和投入的理念。如果你喜欢冬季运动，那太棒了。这是应对冬天的绝佳方式，能进行一些体育锻炼，获得快乐感。但你可以打破常规，滑雪、单板滑雪、溜冰、雪地徒步。这些并不是冬天唯一能做的事情。室内活动也很好。报个班，在群体中保持活跃。
See people. Do things that you like to do. Stay in your routines. Don't make it so that when end of daylight savings rolls around and you come out of work that first Monday and it's dark, which was not the case the Friday before, that you go home and get on the couch under a blanket and go into a hibernation state.
见见人。做你喜欢做的事。保持你的日常作息。不要让夏令时结束、你那个星期一第一次下班时天黑（而前一个星期五天还没黑）的情况发生时，让你直接回家钻进毯子里的沙发上，进入冬眠状态。
That's generally not very effective. The more that you can stay active and engaged and keep doing the very same things that you were doing the Friday before the time change. Stay in your routine. Yes, you'll have to fight a little bit of fatigue, but it's so important to stay active and engaged and keep doing fun things in the winter and not go into hibernation mode. Thank you so much for joining us on the show today, Dr. Rowan. This has been a really great conversation that I think people will be helpful to hear this time of year.
这通常没有什么效果。你越能保持活跃和投入，继续做时钟拨慢前那个星期五一直在做的事情，效果就越好。保持你的日常作息。是的，你得稍微克服一下疲劳，但在冬天保持活跃、投入并继续做有趣的事情，不进入冬眠模式，这是非常重要的。罗文博士，非常感谢你今天来到我们的节目。这是一次非常棒的对话，我想在这个季节听听这些对大家会很有帮助。
And I appreciate those tips on sort of what to do if it's not something so extreme as a seasonal effective disorder. And just one tip for people who do feel like they might fall in to the category of, suffering from seasonal effective disorder, what suggestions do you have? I would strongly recommend to consult with a mental health professional to have a diagnostic interview and make sure that it really is sad and then work from there to navigate what would be an effective treatment plan for you. Could be a psychologist, psychiatrist, community mental health provider. If you're not sure how to get started, ask your primary care provider to make a referral.
我也很感激你分享的这些建议，告诉人们如果情况没有严重到季节性情感障碍的程度时该怎么做。对于那些确实觉得自己可能属于患有季节性情感障碍的人，你有什么建议吗？我强烈建议咨询心理健康专业人士，进行诊断性访谈，以确定这是否真的是季节性情感障碍，然后在此基础上探讨对你来说有效的治疗方案。可以是心理学家、精神科医生或社区心理健康服务提供者。如果你不知道该如何开始，请让你的初级保健医生为你转诊。
Well, thank you so much for your time. We really appreciate it. You are welcome. My pleasure. Before we go, just a reminder that we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, dot org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it.
非常感谢你抽出时间。我们真的很感激。不客气，这是我的荣幸。在离开之前，提醒大家我们很乐意倾听您的意见。您可以将您的评论和想法发电子邮件至 speakingof psychology at APA.org。也就是 speakingof psychology（连在一起写），点 org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分，我们将不胜感激。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcast. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在苹果、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何您收听播客的地方找到《心理学对话》以前的单集。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢娜（Caitlin Luna）。感谢收听。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。